after another mass shooting president
biden now calling to tighten gun laws
i don't need to wait another minute let
alone an hour
to take common sense steps that will
save the lives
in the future nullifying
unconstitutional federal laws is both
legal and it's also the right thing to
do
it's clear as day that a lot of the gun
laws that are being debated now
would totally infringe the second
amendment it could be decades before the
supreme court makes its mind up it's
silly to sit around and wait for
something you know is unconstitutional
it's time to stand up and fight back and
the methods that we need to use are the
ones already being used by the left
in 1987 organ passed a law prohibiting
state and local law enforcement from
using public resources to arrest or
detain people whose only crime was being
in the country illegally
since then hundreds of other
jurisdictions have passed similar laws
becoming what's known as sanctuary
cities there's a new movement among
conservative gun rights activists
to employ the same strategy lawmakers
have introduced bills in more than a
dozen states that would nullify federal
gun control laws
on april 6 arizona governor doug ducey
signed a gun control nullification bill
into law
montana and west virginia's legislatures
have each approved bills that are now
awaiting signature or veto from their
governors
the arkansas senate and the missouri and
south carolina houses have each passed
such bills
and committees in texas alabama and new
hampshire have bills that are moving
forward in their state legislatures and
similar bills have been introduced in
florida
north carolina georgia minnesota
ohio nebraska iowa and louisiana
james madison in federalist 46 he told
us what needs to be done
by individuals cities and states
to defeat federal programs without
relying on the federal government to
limit itself he said specifically
a refusal to cooperate with the officers
of the union this is how you defeat the
feds whether it's an
unconstitutional act or if you just
don't like the policy
michael bolden is the founder and
executive director of the 10th amendment
center
based in los angeles he studies and
advocates for nullification of all kinds
of federal overreach
we know this stuff has been working and
the right can continue to complain about
the things that the left is successful
at
or they can look at it learn from it and
replicate it
i think the strategy is there the
strategies no it's just time to execute
florida state representative anthony
sabatini is a co-sponsor of house bill
1205
otherwise known as the second amendment
preservation act
it prohibits any employee of the state
of florida from enforcing
or attempting to enforce any federal act
law
executive order administrative order
court order
rule regulation statute or ordinance
infringing on the right to keep and bear
arms
as insured by the second amendment if
the bill passes any state employee that
assists in enforcing federal gun control
laws would be permanently terminated
defying federal law is something that
the majority of states already do in one
way or another
in the form of becoming immigration
sanctuaries or through the legalization
and decriminalization of marijuana and
other drugs
well in terms of the method it's
identical what you're doing is basically
saying
we as a state are not going to do
anything to assist
in the enforcement of this
unconstitutional law
so in that sense the method is exactly
the same with marijuana certain drug
laws
basically they just stood down and they
stopped cooperating and what you saw was
sanctuary cities was the same thing they
stopped reporting to and dealing with
ice
and that's basically what we're doing
the federal government is so big today
that it can't enforce
pretty much anything without the help of
state and local law enforcement state
agencies and the like and when you opt
out of enforcement
it renders that nearly impossible to
enforce the atf only has about 5 500
employees for the whole country
about a third of them are in
administration and that means
they don't have the manpower or
resources to enforce federal gun control
on their own their maximum capacity year
in and year out
is between 8 and 10 000 close cases so
if you get a combination
of more than 10 000 people violating a
federal act
and then on top of it you have states
and local communities refusing to
participate in enforcement
you've then opened the door to actually
nullify that federal act
in practice and effect bolden says that
the legal case for nullification doesn't
depend on the constitutionality of the
law that a state wants to nullify
thanks to a legal doctrine known as
anti-commandeering which has been upheld
in five supreme court cases stretching
from 1842
to 2018 it states that the federal
government can't require states and
localities to participate in the
enforcement of federal laws
talking about constitutionality actually
does kind of get in the way
of anti-commandeering because you don't
actually have to address
the constitutionality of something to
say you're not going to participate a
lot of people like that as a line in the
sand
and i think that's a good approach but i
don't think they should be helping
enforce
federal gun control even if a federal
court says
this federal gun control measure is
constitutional
in march of 2018 when the trump
administration was fighting with local
officials over the enforcement of
federal
immigration laws john bolton challenged
the concept of nullification in an
interview with breitbart news daily
the idea that law enforcement at lower
levels
shouldn't be required to cooperate with
the feds is just
unthinkable that was also proposed by
south carolina senator john c
calhoun before the civil war say that
south carolina and other other slave
states would not enforce federal law on
regarding slavery people will use that
line if they just don't like the policy
and of course some people will just fall
in line say well that's evil and racist
but the bottom line is nullification as
a tool banning participation in federal
enforcement was actually a tool
of the anti-slavery abolitionist north
and when south carolina seceded and same
with georgia and mississippi and i think
texas as well
they issued a document to explain their
rationale and they specifically cited
northern nullification of the federal
fugitive slave act sabatini says the
nullification bill he's sponsoring is
popular among voters
which doesn't necessarily mean it's
likely to pass i know that at the
grassroots level
throughout the state of florida this is
one of the most popular bills filed in
the session this year if not the most
popular bill
but you really never know what the
chances are in the legislature in other
states law enforcement groups like the
sheriff's associations in montana
wyoming and missouri
have worked to prevent these laws from
passing or to change language in the
bills to render them effectively useless
bolton says police departments want to
continue enforcing federal law because
it's lucrative
in missouri one of the biggest reasons
that sheriff's association is against it
is they
want to be able to use federal gun
charges
as leverage for marijuana violations or
other drug war issues
and so if you get caught by cops and
you've got a gun
they're going to say you know turn over
your friends or you're going to get an
extra five or an extra two or an extra
10 years under a federal gun
charge and they want to be able to
continue that they get
all kinds of funding for the joint task
forces through the department of
homeland security grant the edward byrne
justice assistance grant they get civil
asset forfeiture i think that is
probably getting in the way i don't
think they'll admit
that like they're getting a bunch of
loot to do this federal enforcement for
them but they certainly are
bolden says that for the nullification
movement to succeed against gun control
laws and beyond
more americans will have to recognize
that the most effective way to oppose
federal policies that violate their
rights
is at the local level the whole idea of
federalism is so important because it's
the only way
you can have a country with a few
hundred million people
living together with a wide range of
social economic political viewpoints
together
in peace what's right for people in
california is probably not right for
people in south carolina and vice versa
and when we see things that come down
from a one-size-fits-all centralized
solution i don't think anyone really
ever gets what they want
and that's why this kind of movement i
think is so important when you reject
a federal centralized approach and you
start taking your own view
locally or on a state level we see how
things can grow and that's exactly
what's happened
now with 36 states define washington dc
on a plant and i think we can replicate
that on other issues
and learn that localism is really the
way forward for liberty